I love that you got to be part of so
many projects that have that resonates
so well with fans I mean you also have a
perfectionist I know and days are like
eating it up it has been the most
incredible few weeks where I think week
six in right now which is crazy at flew
by and you know as a fan myself of the
show I was such a mess in anticipation
and excitement just because I wanted to
make sure we you know we took justice to
the original which was so beloved and
just to see everyone's you know
embracing this show and embracing a even
my character and seeing everyone's
reaction every week has been so exciting
how do you feel about how they dealt
with the Emison of it all you know what
I think there's no there's no news
handsome man no nothing and honey that
band honey is performing today he's a
rock song I'm gonna be front row and
screaming my head off I love you my
earring came up again state law really
big seeing msyn
you know who knows what's going to
happen in the future I think right now
in in the place they were in each
other's lives I think it was a a
necessary thing else and is so far away
and you know relationships aren't easy
but um I have hope you guys hear that
this is a big deal has che been on set
che has and Ashley has Spencer has che
hasn't yet but but I'm sure she'll oh
baby yeah yeah what's coming down the
pipeline like tell me about Ava's
journey what what should we expect my
gosh you know Ava it's been such a
whirlwind telling her storage there's
such darkness in the world that Beacon
Heights and especially in Ava's story
she's such a fighter to survivor she was
abandoned by her parents and yet has you
know proven to her something to the
world that she will be everything that
they are not and add to that the fact
that she's being framed for murder the
love of her life died so much has
happened and yet you know she's such a
light in the same way there's a lot more
drama that unfolds with her father
possible love interest
I love seeing their friendship develop
with three perfectionist like that it's
gonna get better and better every
episode and the bond just becomes
stronger as well as with Mona and Alison
to like the five of us you'll see more
of the five of us but Ava's journey the
yearn for a ride with this one there a
theme coming up that you're very excited
for fans to get to see yeah there's one
in particular I think coming up it's in
a few weeks actually every week there's
one that I love but there's one that I
have in my mind that I can't say why but
it's incredibly cathartic when it does
happen
who does it involve I can't say I know
but it's it's a really emotional scene
[Music]
[Applause]